la bonne humeur de guy lordinot après
son audition cordial à la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur le chlordécone
l'ancien député était invité pour
expliquer le contexte dans lequel il
avait en 1990 demandé une prolongation
d'utilisation du pesticide sa question
écrite est connu guy lordinot a expliqué
ce matin qu'il n'avait fait que relayer
je ne sais pas plus pour
j'ai posé la question après déjà la plus
honnête sincère avait en face de lui des
collègues parlementaires pas tout à fait
à l'aise pour bousculer l'un des leurs
serge letchimy le président de la
commission pose la question de la
responsabilité de l'état qui savaient le
produit dangereux
nous avons le sentiment qu'il n'a pas et
puis je recommande l'usagé stock et qui
a osé volonté de produire pendant cette
période
dutoit de 91-92 qu'après c'est
extrêmement dangereux sur le bief grave
tu peux seulement dire que comme la
formation des fêtes comme on la
consommation et des solutions du stock
on peut difficilement guy lordinot
approuve l'état a failli dit il et
d'affirmer qu'il a vu du chlordécone
circuler dans les années 2000 dans la
banane soit dix ans après l'interdiction
officielle mais il refuse d'en dire plus
donnez nous des précisions vous avez vu
ça où con
avez vous pas alors qu'est ce qui vous
gêne c'est pas vous qui l'avez épandez
dit non la fed est révolu retraités
retiré des affaires donc de saison
passée saison passée et puis bon et ça
n'apporte rien au final
l'audition de l'ancien député lui aura
surtout permis d'affirmer qu'il avait
servi de bouc émissaire dans un sujet
sur lequel peu était informé à l'époque
guy lordinot qui a reconnu quand même
qu'aujourd'hui il n'aurait pas fait la
même demande de prolongation